notre dernier candidat yoran bien
clairement où ils sont dépendants
bonjour monsieur l'électricien et une
moustache du don et la vanne moustache
j'ai vu et les cas c'est ce message non
mais je la vois elle voulait pas qu'on
sache que je porte des lunettes alors
elle les a enlevées voilà pour les
remettre maintenant un iphone c'est lui
met d'habitude
hélas les avaient enlevés pour pas qu'on
voit qu'il porte des lunettes et
drôlement gentille maman comment c'est
son petit nom vengeance il vient n'est
pas pas commencé son champ pôle il a une
bonne bouille jean-paul il boit de l'eau
du vin j'en étais sûr c'est un copain à
moi combien il boit par jour
toile et par jour autant j'ai eu deux
shows dit toi tu vois pas mains du roi
du sirop maman bois du l'un d'eux